you're in the speedforce Barry Oliver
the ANSI monitors the dawn of time he's
extremely powerful date us might not be
enough where did you sing them somewhere
you can't touch up why any means
necessary to their very last breath
[Music]
what the hell just happened where are we
this is the vanishing point what does
that mean it's a point outside of time
and space
what happened to the Waverider and the
others the anti-monitor he used
Harbinger to attack us pariah must have
sent us here knowing that the
anti-monitor couldn't follow well you
have to go back we have to go back right
now we can't they're gone
[Music]
oh I am so happy that worked what what
did you do
well I held the book of destiny and I
saw you seven Paragons due to be
stranded at the vanishing point and I
thought destiny could use a little
rewrite
so
what do we do now
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my crisis on Infinite Earths
part 2 trailer video we also have some
really cool black Adam in Shazam news
that I'll talk about during the video as
well
everyone pour one out for the multiverse
there's a whole bunch of footage that we
have to break down we're doing a new
round of that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your best theory about how
this is going to end on the video
obviously careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened during crisis
on Infinite Earths so far there's still
two more episodes so part two is episode
4 and episode 5 of the crossover there's
no official synopsis for episode 4 yet
but that's going to be the arrow episode
that's why you're seeing so much Oliver
Queen as the Spectre talking to Barry
Allen and the Speed Force during this
since he's become the new Spectre he's
now one of the most powerful characters
in the DC Universe as the spectre he's
really only answerable to God himself
whoever the god of the arrow verse is
going to be don't know if they're gonna
do a Chuck twist from Supernatural if
you've never watched Supernatural they
deal a lot with angels demons God the
devil all that stuff so there is a God
on that TV show and his name is Chuck
they refer to him just like you would
refer to a normal person he just happens
to be completely omnipotent but we've
never met anything like that inside the
arrow verse before don't know if we're
gonna meet him or if they'll just
reference him with some clever dialogue
that Oliver gives them because once
Oliver becomes the spectre he would gain
all that divine knowledge but as you see
during that ending scene pariah Welles
sent the seven Paragons to the vanishing
point to protect them from getting wiped
by the antimatter wave when the
anti-monitor wiped the rest of the
multiverse really it was just one earth
that was left and he just got rid of
that as Oliver explains the anti-monitor
is now going to the dawn of time to
begin creating the antimatter universe
to replace the multiverse he said that
we get all their backstories during the
second half of the crossover he called
him mobius when they were fighting each
other and said that it was a mistake to
allow his creation in the first place
but I'm assuming that they're gonna be
borrowing from a bunch of different
comics for the anti-monitor backstory he
only became the möbius character during
the new 52 so the original crisis on
Infinite Earths backstory for the
anti-monitor
is a little bit different from his
backstory right now in the modern
rebirth comics but in the footage you
see Barry getting knocked around
inside the vanishing point maybe trying
to use his powers outside of space-time
and them just not working quite right
until all of her as the new Spectre of
the multiverse takes him into the Speed
Force to explain the plan to him you're
in the Speed Force Berry now shut the
hell up while I tell you what's going on
just one of the really cool things about
Oliver becoming the new Spectre is that
he's no longer bound by space-time
anymore so it's really easy for him to
take them from the vanishing point to
where the anti-monitor is on this planet
here at the dawn of time there's a
moment during the trailer that if you
blink you probably missed it but the
reverse flash comes back and you see him
running through the Speed Force it's not
clear where he's going or if he's just
trying to hide out in the negative Speed
Force to escape the antimatter wave and
everything the anti-monitor is doing
there was an easter egg in Nora's future
newspaper during season 5 that made it
sound like he was helping the
anti-monitor during crisis on Infinite
Earths willingly or unwillingly because
we found out that the john wesley shipp
earth 90 Barry Allen flesh was forced to
help him early prediction the
reverse-flash will find a way to help
Barry save the multiverse willingly or
unwillingly sometimes he has to help
Barry against his better judgment like
he still hates Barry but his instinct
for self-preservation will probably lead
him to conclude that it's better that he
helped Barry rather than work against
him if he were forced to serve the anti
mater he would hate it just as much as
anybody else even though he is
technically a villain this big red ring
of red energy in the sky seems like it's
his antimatter powers in the act of
creating the new antimatter universe and
then obviously you see all those scenes
of the seven Paragons rushing him trying
to fight him lex luthor using what looks
like a kryptonite based weapon the
really misleading thing about this
trailer is that he's probably 200 P at
this point and none of their combined
powers will be enough to physically
defeat him as a group or even one-on-one
but thinking about some of the seminal
comic book moments and panels from
crisis on Infinite Earths maybe with the
combined help of Oliver Queen's powers
as the spectre they're able to defeat
him and that's part of the idea think
about this giant comic book ending with
everybody bum-rushing the anti-monitor
at the same time this is giant splash
page this is sort of their avengers
endgame
Avengers Assemble moment but you also
have to imagine that Oliver Queen has
this crazy godlike power now and he's
coming at him
let me know in the comments if you do
think they're gonna go for the obvious
you have failed this multiverse line or
you have failed this city in some form
or another because there was actually a
classic Batman comic with the specter
crossover where the spectre says you
have failed this city
and now the Oliver's the spectre why
wouldn't he say his signature line I
know you have a lot of big questions
about Green Lantern Corps what's going
on with them during this crossover
they're gonna tease it because they are
working on a brand new Green Lantern
series for HBO max there's supposed to
be a star girl teaser even though that's
kind of a Lester's thing she's not
really a big character but that's gonna
be one of the new CW shows in the next
couple of years but there's also
supposed to be a moment with three
versions of Superman on screen at the
same time and since we haven't seen that
yet I'm assuming it's when the
multiverse comes back when they fix
everything
early guess is it's going to be Kingdom
Come Superman coming back Tyler hoechlin
Superman from Earth 38 in maybe Tom
Wellings Superman coming back that would
feel like the best payoff
maybe they'll tease the formation of a
quote-unquote league without straight up
calling it Justice League because I
still think that they're not allowed to
use the Justice League name on the TV
shows yet early prediction for next
year's crossover - because how do you
beat crisis on Infinite Earths how do
you go bigger than that and the answer
is blackest night so what they might do
because they're doing the new Green
Lantern series is that they'll start to
introduce Green Lantern stuff during
next year's crossover and make the slow
march to the next couple of years where
they eventually work up to blackest
night but something that big will take
them a couple years to work up - you
don't go straight to blackest night
first you have to introduce the Green
Lantern Corps then you have to introduce
the Sinestro Corps and all the other
different colors of the emotional
spectrum and their individual Lantern
cords then you can finally do blackest
night the really cool black Adam in
Shazam news that they announced while I
was making this video is that Shazam 2
is gonna come out just a couple months
after Black Adam so just a reminder
Black Adam is coming out December 2021
still a little ways off they're gonna be
filming it next year that movie is
mostly gonna be set in the past they'll
be introducing the Justice Society of
the DC movie universe the DC EU but then
a couple months after that they'll do
Shazam - with the Shazam League going
inside the magic lands and then they'll
have their big crossover with black
versus the Shazam Li the really big
Shazam black atom Easter eggs that have
been part of crisis on Infinite Earths
TV stuff is all the eternium in the
lead-up to crisis on Infinite Earths
nash wells was trying to hunt down
eternium eternium is basically shards of
the rock of eternity so that's them just
starting to do some Shazam stuff within
the arrowverse but I don't know how
they're gonna handle the Shazam
characters eventually I think eventually
you will see a version of that character
on the TV shows but it might be a while
before that happens there's a whole
bunch of stuff happening this week as
long as you have alerts you should see
all the videos when I post them but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
everyone click here for all the crisis
on Infinite Earths episodes and click
here to rewatch that Wonder Woman 1984
trailer a billion more times thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]